voyez-vous nelson cette étude culinaire
que vous avez été faire en france était
très importante à nos yeux nous avions
besoin de savoir comment la cuisine
française était perçu par un anglais
alors un show votre premier commentaire
je dois dire demain à 10 heures julien
que compte tenu de tout ce que l'on dit
sur la cuisine chez nous vous pensez
bien que ce voyage d'étude rhdp très
très grande importance à mes yeux le
rendez vous avec les françaises c'est
française qui monte et pathé dans tous
les sens du mot et notamment dans celui
de leur capacité à parler les langues
étrangères et chattes comme guide
mais que dire des guides qui avec nick
matthew et l'unc et qu'il n'y avait que
beaucoup voient là acquis à monza
guitare et canailles white ap
ça veut dire on aille à revers et un
arrêt que là et que hugh laurie a des
choses à toutes et à tous ma merde
nelson je vous connais que trop votre
sérieux certes à la rédaction de cette
thèse sur l'art culinaire français mais
les françaises ont bien dû vous
enseignez d'autres choses je dois dire
qu'elles sont parfaitement à la hauteur
de leur réputation
j ai trouvé chez elle magie poésie amour
humour il ya duo de l'ère du las
martinés du shakespeare réunis c'était
une très très belle expérience
tu l'as entendu l'amour de domaine de
seconde la torah de nuit non pour avoir
appliqué et 10 passes en premier toit et
moi je passais un dernier jeu donnant
une tisane il va dormir j'ai pris la
pilule pour ce soir et tout se montrer
la merde et moi je suis prudente et
régis bonjour on voulait à mon argent
maintenant je fais attention je
souhaitais gorge mais blanc ouvre sa va
voir où leurs chers alors il a combien
de poule est alors au tour de l'île à
bord sather il en a eu deux compères ils
veulent avoir plus mais mme merkel et
donner du plaisir à une trentaine d
pouze vers me l'ont pas dit
personnellement mais je pense que oui
pas mal dans la des femmes c'est pas mal
je remarque que certains animaux étaient
plus vigoureux clé il faut bien dire je
vous la conseille parce que sous mes
narines c'est vraiment ça me qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais c'est excellent
et ça sent très bon et puis ce goût d'un
il a peu à peu les faire l'amour mais
après ça bien un seul ingrédient nous
n'aurons pas le temps de faire
aujourd'hui les choux aux escargots pour
une prochaine fois
alors au revoir et à bientôt à bishop's
mais c'est sa vessie et qui s'ils
deviennent tout à l'heure la de cette
fois il faut jamais me dire mon agent ne
m'a chassé de chansons quand il faut pas
dans les parent et d'amour après la
purée d'ail là c'est foutu maintenant je
suis tout à fait excellent mieux
elle sonne on connaît le raffinement des
françaises quand il s'agit de faire de
la cuisine mais dans l'intimité
j'étais justement en train d'y rêver
dans l'intimité tout n'est que douceur
tendresse caresse générosité surtout
surtout une infinie douceur ou maïté là
vous me racontez des histoires
il ya des oeufs aux as mais je n'invente
pas que c'est pas neuf vous êtes sur
certaines qu'est ce que c'est les
claques c cocoa c'est l'écho
bon je crois que je comprends ce que
voulait dire un obsédant commun qu'est
ce que vous n'aimez dise ce que vous
venez de me diront j'ai tout vu à
l'extérieur je comprends pas ce que
voulait me revoir
et là il en à l'intérieur bon tout le
monde a compris c'est pas des se saborde
intérieur avec ça en fait quand même des
jolies poulet comment dirais-je
j'ai toujours lu ou entendu que la
cuisine était révélatrice de troubles
psychologiques notamment dans la façon
de faire les plats vous avez noté des
choses similaires troubles dites vous
ce que j'ai en tout cas constater c'est
que les françaises semblaient
véritablement avoir la cuisine ancré au
fond d'elle-même et à travers leurs
plats ma foi il n'est pas surprenant que
certains éléments historiques
ressurgissent un exemple précis pour
être tout à fait précis je dirais que
les françaises font peut-être tout
simplement le complexe de jeanne d'arc
on va la flambée avec la fine champagne
ça y est ça brûle regarder
voilà ça peut pas être mauvais vous avez
cependant et maintenant je vais sortir
les morceaux nos bleus oui voilà mon
voisin rc lomagne hb à eh ben ils
bougent la ville que c'est parce que
vous allez le flamber bien je vais
flamber les bordeaux voilà il faut pas
les mettre là et ça va finir de les
revendre et un petit et on va leur
donner un bon étudiant la regarder ça
voilà vous délicieux bien sûr très bien
et alors ensuite une fois on avait dit
pas tout à fait cuit en tout donc elle
qui va pouvoir faire alors je vais les
mettre dans ma sauce j'ai mis mon pastis
à chauffer au fait alors là là un petit
coup de feu un petit coup de feu c'est
comme à l'armagnac ici pour sa flamme
oui voilà or sa pomme moinat me trouve
pas de casseroles et cofor
et ce à l'aide à cuire
nelson revenons quelques instants quand
même sur votre sur votre voyage en
france sur ce voyage scientifique ce
voyage culinaire avez vous remarqué ô
combien les français sont attachés à
notre patrimoine les grands noms de la
cuisine française sa courte à des grands
noms les grands chefs vous l'avez dit
absolument il ya là un véritable
héritage un respect permanent
ces grands chefs qu'elle n'hésite pas à
citer le plus souvent rapidement demandé
dans l'art fait de vos culs celui-là il
ajoute le porte au madère où le vin
blanc au 2t quoi tout à fait à la fin
quand ça a été passé il ne fait pas rire
avec
il s'appelle vaucluse alors vas-y tu es
tu fasses vaucluse vaucluse
ah si vous en rappelez pas vous tromper
les poivrons de trois couleurs ça fait
rare d'en voir des journées les jeunes
louis méric c'est plus joli et puis
c'est bon c'est assez bon pour les
rouges et les verts c'est plus banal
thomas ce qu'est ce que vous en avez
saint lô la lâchent les mondes et ça
fait venir
oui j'ai coupé en petits morceaux et
avant que la bière et ses fins la rue ou
dans les livres de cuisine en 3 du
vocabulaire évidemment qu est pas
toujours le merveilleux qui me va pas du
tout allez moi je crois que là c'est
chaud non mais ne me mettre dans
l'assiette
nous on en vient des froides mais non
parce que c'est ça vous sur les bords
mais mettez le doigt un jeu de terre non
mais on va pas le manger on va le
montrer c'est le mnr août et que c'est
chaud oui
c'est chaud se tienne on ne sait jamais
comment voulez-vous que voici les cuit
et rené j'étais inquiet dans l'eau bon
alors vous accréditent magicienne et
vous savez voir comme ça si c'est
curieux de moi je vous dis le voilà à
vous d'essayer un nouveau contre l'
année c'est bon je vous dise qu'il est
très soudée dont j'aurais gagné un peu
de tarbes reçoit s'en sortir la sueur
voilà et l'île du roi pour moi il vaut
mieux attendre du bruit un jour elle
vient faire sens évident que vous ça
vraiment on dira que c'est enfantin et
vous savez j'ai essayé c'est pas si
facile que ça finalement
surtout là pour trouver le
l'articulation soyez vous tapez ne vous
impressionner par les brasseurs tête et
que ça fait plaisir et se faire voir
envoyés dans les camps rien et voilà
c'est marrant je vous ai porté malchance
je suis pas fâché parce que ça m'est
arrivé souvent
c'est pas facile aulas il repart coupé
beaucoup parce que toulouse et nous sont
en berne
et là je tout au sable il y en a qui
croient qu'on s'amuse oui où il est sec
le corner le micro ils valent pas un sou
y aller
de saison oui surtout ça je suis en
train de me concentrer ou piriou
enfin delson permettez-moi de
m'interroger ça n'a pas dû être facile
quand même ce voyage culinaire barrière
de culture barrière de langue comment
avez vous pu appréhender toutes ces
techniques culinaires
ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement et les mots pour le dire
arrivent aisément
j'ai retrouvé chez les françaises
un véritable amour des termes de cuisine
et des explications parfaitement clair
voilà mesdames mesdemoiselles et
messieurs le mou bien enfermée là je
vais mettre un petit peu froid mais
parce que olala ça aurait claqué son ré
claqué alors bon là ça va pareil mais
pour nous pour vous pour nous sa poule
oui enfin je m'explique pour nous ça ne
va pas mais pour vous ces bornes
parce qu'on vous a mis dans ce pot pour
vous montrer pouvait t impôt un peu plus
grand et vous le coup vrai et vous
laissez bouillir 2 heures mais comme
annoncé dès trop important pour un pot
alors on a mis comme ça que vous avez
tous compris qu'il fallait pas faire
comme ça voilà allant vous remplissez
d'eau
il y ait de l'eau à ras bord et vous
laissez bouillir 2 heures de temps
alors de ce côté là c'est la daube c'est
le doigt vers mon jeu alors c'est
beaucoup plus foncée oui il ya les
carottes l'équivalent de carottes et le
goût était plus épicée plus fort c'est
pas pareil ça s'est fait presque pareil
mais c'est tout à fait différent on a
des coquilles saint-jacques toute
fraîche tout ben nous avons des tomates
nous avons des pas lourds bain des
belges huîtres a pris hier des échanges
entre toujours pareil du thym et du
laurier du persil ne laisse pas de lui
du vinaigre c'est bien entendu des
coques des petits crabes et voilà c'est
très bien sauf que moi je savais pas que
ça c'était 18 maïté moi j'appelle ça
plutôt des moules en jeu du résultat et
oui c'est ma grand faim qu'est ce que
vous croyez moi commence
mais voilà erreurs de la lourde
un épais brouillard commençait alors on
commence il faut deux blancs d'oeuf par
kg de sel et à votre avis pour un poulet
gros comme ça il faudra combien de
rigolo quand nous allons c'est à dire
les voilà donc quatre kilos dawson là ça
fait beaucoup quand même hein ça fait
beaucoup mais vous allez voir un défaut
alors maintenant les jeunes voulaient je
sortais je l'aimé le côté et jean
follain de la canne anglaise elle vient
sur en eux je peux rire et je croyais
que tu es mort c'est l'un comprend
qu'elle ait conquet les couilles de dire
si vous savez pas écouter ce que ces
moments je suis bon il a vécu des mois
c'est les poissons des poissons fait de
la merde ça
non je crois que ce serait à lui passé
de la famille de la pieuvre on va dire
voulait qu'on le dit non non non ah oui
de quoi céphalopode céphalopode avait
vendu c'est ce qu'elle a appris l'ap et
parker des foires aux livres à la main
bonjour bonjour
mais qu'est ce que nous avons devant
nous sont curieux animaux la spa et
c'est la famille de la pieuvre a très
bien et ça c'est découvrement dit c'est
pas tout à fait des mollusques l'aider
comment ce qu on appelle ça du château
exactement ça bon très bien mais c'est
pas là quelque chose assez rare g et
cécile et radio - nelson vous avez eu
accès à des endroits privilégiés comme
les cuisines des grands restaurants
comment ça se passe entre les membres du
personnel en cuisine la principale
conclusion de ma thèse mahdia julien
c'est que une fois que la recette est
donné le consensus est totale tout le
monde est d'accord et bien méritée après
ce homard du pays bas oui accompagné de
ses pommes de terre persillées facile il
nous reste un peu tort peut-être pour
faire une autre recette oui un autre à
mare un autre nom une araignée 9 crois
qu'on va faire d'abord un homard aux
herbes
bonjour bonjour maïté quel est le menu
du jour ne me rappelle plus la brandade
et la mairie d'epinal a brûlé pays
basque à s'allier trois minutes au four
et ensuite
maïté est-ce que vous avez encore une
autre recette de mots bien sûr on va
faire la mouclade donna au maire
d'angers chercher le nom de dieu nous on
est là pour des amoureux sur la plage le
sel le poivre
mais les herbes qu'on a coupé très bien
vous voulez je vous prépare les yeux je
voulais tellement vous les verrez vos
herbes
voilà je mets en nous expliquant bien ce
que vous mettez jeu mais tout ça c'est
le persil ça c'est la ciboulette
ça c'est bien vrai ça c'est riche à
l'autre le persil et là il tout ça je
suis désolé mais il faut couper parce
que les jeux ne sont pas durs ils sont
mous on est salon alors ça je ne sais
pas comment voulez que je fasse avec ça
et nous avons un problème sérieux
mais nelson la grande cuisine à longueur
de journée les saveurs les odeurs ça
doit vous travaillez un petit peu à
force je dois dire qu'il m'arrivait d'en
rêver la nuit imaginez-vous seulement
ses senteurs comme vous le dites si
unique si miraculeuse en rêver la nuit
c'est vrai
malheureusement ce n'était qu'un rêve
e
et
benson inverse est un leurre car là je
veux commencer à voir une petite soif
des armes au nelson la cuisine française
n'est-elle pas paradoxal n'existe-t-il
pas un paradoxe entre la façon de
préparer la recette est le plat final
c'est une très bonne question et je dois
vous dire que j'ai été un petit peu déçu
je m'attendais à ce que les choses
bougent davantage dans cette cuisine
j'ai trouvé l'atmosphère un petit peu
éteinte
bonjour bonjour maïs qui s'est passé
vide à la main ou faut faire vite
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bon que se
monnaye merde tu regardes gens avec mes
verres de temps cheville et un joli
derby on a même envoyé combattre et j'ai
pour quelque chose paraissait j'avais
sur le sol
et georges tu te mets pour l' usap et le
plateau c'est ça ou mettez c'est plutôt
d'un jeu un petit peu je croyais parfois
on se régale et convient de savoir si
les rançons
avais je voudrais pourra jamais les
bastilles amené aussi souple qu'un ce
moment alors nous mais on va essayer on
va voir quelle recette on va faire avec
du boeuf de chalosse bien entendu non
plus laisser la place et c'est moi je
vais pas pleurer
voilà quand je vais t'en rends le mans
petit il ya peut-être quelque chose que
vous avez remarqué nelson c'est le
respect du cuisinier face à l'animal
respect du cuisinier face à l'animal et
peut-être aussi l' inverse j'ai surtout
en fait remarquer linverse sa part est
peut-être un peu bizarre mais lorsqu'un
animal c'est qu'il va être cuisinée par
ces augustes main il semble être tout
d'un coup victime d'une dévotion totale
parra et respect tout simplement une
croix de bois il accepte la décision
d'un poulet on a expliqué dans le
sud-ouest pour qu'il soit bon il faut
qu'ils aient couru en liberté mais qu'il
y filer quelque chose devant se mettre
sous la dent exactement
voilà ses courses à rien alors celui là
nous avons je voulais qu'ils viennent à
côté de chez vous tous vivent bien sûr
tous vivants il est très simple il est
comme les chats quand on me gratte le
cool péronne le pauvre est alors pour
l'accommoder il faudra quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on s'emmerde
c'est merveilleux la vie est belle la
vie est belle de belles toujours mais en
réalité formidable et tous laïques ci
doit résoudre c'est très agréable et ma
biche biche oh ma biche comme tu glisses
fais moi voir tes jolies zillow prenez
votre nom s'amuse ce sont des gambas ou
avait dit on alors j'ai fait le saut de
l'espoir de l'aviron oui elles sont pas
méditerranéenne élevés en liberté ces
cousines germaines alors qu'il va
falloir faire maintenant bon allons
maintenant il faut les tuer bien large
regardez cette belle mort qu'ils ont eux
mêmes oui c'est cela ma chérie voilà un
bon ballon et pendant ce temps je vais
faire que des légumes
vous avez mis dans quoi vous à marc
maniatis vous demande pardon' bbc
rigueur et oui mais non enfin sérieuse
avant d'atterrir mais ça et c'est démago
la regarder ça et cela va donner
elles sont sous le feu des garçons sa
lampe allait profiter
profitez de la vie bresse les enfants
profiter de la riveraine
vous voyez qu'on les apprécie oui et oui
eh ben voilà
regardez ce soit et c'est beau
aujourd'hui regarder la coupe à la casse
et la annonce deux ans j'étais marjo et
n'importe quoi et mon petit je t'ai fait
mal
le show vous êtes bête avec vous êtes
bêtes bombay
qu'est ce que tu as fais mon petit ils
sont 6 1% en avril à dans une coque
maintenant barjon mecheri et de deux
parts est vrai que c'est pas du tout
comme ça ça peut penser très fort
cependant ces balades sont partis en
arrière alors on va mettre ce matin sans
effet a trop besoin de mettre des
légumes bio à déporter voulait que vous
pas un peu de carottes
oui mais que rien ne vous avez un
précédent train de mourir dans le poivre
alors ça c'était pas prévu autant pour
moi c'est un peu dommage certes pas dans
ma mère donne un goût
eh bien il va falloir les assommer et
les tuer il entendu voilà alors pour les
tuer
je vais peut-être la somme et on va voir
mais autrement il faut les 1,6 et dans
tout le tour voilà il faut l'exercice de
tous les tours et bourges par la chérie
ne bouge pas ma chérie enregistre ses
liens et après on l'appelle aïe aïe aïe
oui oui oui
allez hop au viêt-nam a plus y'en a
marre puisse alors là j'ai pas mâché
forme
oui vous allez voir et la peur et
micheline payez pas fait remonter de la
voile mais après ce que vous lui avez
raconté évidemment un
la voilà et bien vous allez voir hier
n'avait plus rien à ma vie vient là bas
il faut pas être un grain de tenue et et
oui et c'est glissant il tient votre
chiffre à peu près au que oui oula ça
met un petit coup la poudre je crois que
ça ne lui suffit même pas tu n'auras pas
ma peau
dites moi c'est vigousse l'entêté la
terrible elle avait l'air de vouloir
dormir et ses rires ça y est qu'est-ce
qui lé gard mais le pineau mélanie elle
est restée elle est morte car mais alors
ça fait rien qu'est ce qu'il faut pas
faire pour gagner sa croûte
c'est pas vrai on va le couper en
tranches très bien qu'est ce que c'est
il est vivant
voilà
elle serait permettez moi d bassement
matérialiste mais ce voyage en france a
dû vous coûter une petite fortune
où avez vous trouvé leur joie feuille de
temps que nous autres britanniques ne
sommes pas connus pour être
particulièrement généreux de nos deniers
non je ne suis pas parti tout seul comme
ça avec mon propre portefeuille
je suis partie grâce au soutien fidèle
d'un partenaire d'un sponsor d'ailleurs
je lui ai promis un petit passage dans
notre émission alors si vous lui
permettez
dans le côté human en accord avec les
disques rionnais présente la compilation
laser des meilleurs titres de maïté
l'arinella les petites marionnettes
thomas n'est pas à nous sommes aux
poches profondes faut pendant que c'est
triste venise
mais c'est vrai ya le poulet a pu faire
plus mais encore là et je vois une
église au fond d'eux à mauguio fronde
ramon ou la fin cloche ses souvenirs
dans l'eau et bien sûr la dacquoise la
compilation laser regroupant les
meilleurs titres de maïté avec rio
production c'est une production par
coleman
soit on avait des filles mais dans les
prés fleuris
l ol et paris
mason vous aurez certainement remarqué
le raffinement des cuisines français
cette façon par les services le
raffinement oui j'avais remarqué mais je
n'en serai pas fiers du tout à votre
place pourquoi ça je trouve que le
langage des grands chefs échappe
complètement aux gens de la rue aux gens
de la rue de tous les jours c'est un
langage qui s'adresse à l'élite
intellectuelle de votre pays qui échappe
au plus grand nombre
en plus c'est un langage que j'ai trouvé
de toute façon beaucoup trop sophistiqué
et beaucoup trop raffiné annaba est
reparti mon kiki
non pas que les jeux ne sont pas des
marraines se croient pas il en manque
toujours de rue mais dans la très bonne
bonjour bonjour
maïté qu'est ce que vous allez nous
faire aujourd'hui de la morue est alors
comment est ce que vous allez nous l'a
connu à l'accommoder parce qu'elle est
remportée de morue et bien entendu ce
n'est pas l'entente qu'on apprenne c'est
bon jeu mais c'est comme ça m collet
pour le restant de vos jours
il est frais ou ton père si non c'est
bon parce que dans le coup et
c'est bon ça va mal perdu par les allées
oliva belle bête qu'est ce que vous avez
l'intention d'en faire
bon et bien on va faire le civet de
sanglier on va faire la terrine de
sanglier et sur la tare de gigot de cinq
milliers de cristaux j'ai quelquefois
manger ça c'est fameusement bon quand
même
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
commencer c'est très noble olalala verre
d'eau ou est-ce qu'on a dû longtemps
abonnée à la beauté c'est ça ouyahia
saisi bon voyez-vous - kanna mène de
narrer vous roulez la ligue on doit
aller il m'arrive souvent de de comparer
une cuisine et une entreprise le sens de
la hiérarchie très important le sens de
la hiérarchie le respect très important
m'a aidé à julien c'est même l'un des
axes essentiels de ma thèse dans toutes
les cuisines que j'ai pu visiter
j'ai constaté un réel respect de la
décision du chef il impose le calme
le silence l'obéissance ces décisions
font force de loi je les sens si ça doit
aller et c'est vrai même plus et on ne
savait qu'on pouvait pas bien pourquoi
nous dis pas que c'est bien d'avoir
recommencé le sait bien c'est pas bien
héros
la civilité pas content avec ça le maire
d'alors y mêlant d'honorer c'est la
bonne note au rec et je vais mettre à
côté de l'armagnac pour flamber tout
saatchi car il sera cuit
je voudrais bien me lie baiser canard là
vous y attend départ et j'ai vu les g de
phrasé soleil au lycée de relier les
gorges lui aurait coûté moi si vous êtes
sous je n'y peux rien les oreilles à des
cotons tiges il veut je n'ai jamais dit
sale of thé japonais [ __ ] en faire
des châteaux [ __ ]
alors il nous faut tout d'abord de
l'armagnac toujours pareil
après le faux du poireau et des carottes
non ce sont des pommes de terre ne
croyez-vous pas oh merde non ça ne va
pas c'était mou c'était quoi aller
chanter on vous a pas écouté un camp
qu'est ce qu'il va nous sortir sa gueule
mais je suis j'ai pas bougé beaucoup et
là on y gagne et j'ai fait attention et
de la lie aux me suivent et ben ça on
n'a que ça à [ __ ]
c'est pas vrai ou quoi il faut
recommencer
non qu'on allait paraissait bic est
plate et ça bougeait quand même un os
ils sont en mer d'un seul à refroidir
pour voir ce long et le voulez vous show
où le voulez vous froid comme à la
fronde tels miracles
attention non mais parce qu'il faut pas
refaire a laissé voir maintenant
décodées par aof
mais oui pourtant je suis bien la nature
mais c est parti ce qui m'énerve jamie
choi se redresse et faire croire vous
savez pas puisque ces derniers jours
alors soyez décontractée
ouf
vous comptez qu à nelson mahdia julien
pour autant que je puisse compter je
m'aperçois que je n'ai bu que 13 vert et
le chiffre 13 porte malheur chez nous
comme chez vous du reste c'est le 14e
qui vous ramènera chez vous absolument
pour autant que je puisse me lever on
reparlera de cuisine une autre fois en
attendant grasset la cuisine plus de
nous qu'est-ce qu'on a pas vu maïté
aulas l'a appris j'ai été bien gentil
quand même y en aura pas désagréable du
tout l'ambiance aussi dit pour revenir
sérieux hein il faut penser à la
rochelle recèlent bien au revoir à
bientôt 1 et à votre santé à tous un
richard